[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think with Dear John
and Hank it's that comedy podcast where
me and my brother John week and I'm
farting so I'm just gonna let that go
and then I'm gonna start over again
great good plan it's a comedy podcast
for me and my brother John we answer
your question give you to be suffice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon how are you John
I'm a little bit stressed out to be
honest I've got just a lot of work
stress I've got a lot of work I blame
you for this actually Hank because if
none of my work stress comes from
sitting alone in a basement and trying
to write a novel
it all comes from you I think some of it
comes from sitting alone in a basement
and trying to write a novel so well I
haven't really written in about a month
and a half so it can't it can't be that
at the moment I well I didn't sleep very
much last night and and I but I'm still
a huge fan of my child sometimes when
he's uh he's crying at night I'll go to
his cradle and I'll go to try and soothe
him but I don't want him to see me
because that will wake him up more yeah
and so he'll be crying and then I like
tried to sneak up to his cradle and then
I'll look at his face to see what he
looks like
yeah it'll make eye contact with me and
it just smiles oh I'm like no dude sweet
it is
but like go to sleep I thought you were
gonna say that he can he can sense you
or hear you and he wakes up and starts
crying but yeah I mean it's very hard to
get babies to sleep Hank there is no
there is no magic to it it's just very
I'd I'm very sorry that's all I can say
I'm stuttering and stumbling because I
just I feel for you it is really hard to
go through the world extremely tired
yeah do you know John we actually have
several questions from people who have
had problems with their baby sleeping
which is the first time I've noticed
that which is fine but we we don't want
to get there yet we've got to get to the
short poem okay you can do that thank
you I appreciate that today's short poem
comes from Kobayashi Issa and it's a
haiku Hank I know you love haikus I
really love this I COO somebody sent it
in
listener to dear Hank and Joe thanks for
sending it in it goes like this the Ren
earns his living noiselessly it's good
very good huh it's everything I want to
haiku to be Hank I have a question for
you that's related to the Ren earning
its living noiselessly are you gonna ask
how we could earn our living noiselessly
because I think that would be really
hard because part of what we do is make
noise it's like kind of our thing yeah
that's what I was gonna ask is there any
way we could move to say like a John
Cage for minutes and 33 seconds style
podcast it's just well we could do that
once I think we can put out of just a
just the short poem and then it would
just be silence for the rest of the
podcast people would love it people
would love it people would love it Hank
yeah I want to read to you a question
okay
it comes from crystal Hank and I are
both very tired I don't know if you guys
can tell this comes from crystal who
writes Dear John and Hank I have a brand
new four week old baby when does it stop
sucking both could be wrong she's
beautiful and magical and I love her but
it sucks help a mama out give me a light
at the end of the baby-shaped
tunnel crystal I do think that when the
smiling starts happening Matt that does
help quite a lot smiling is great you
know what's even better is like talking
once they can really communicate with
you although you know that comes with
its own set of disadvantages I I have a
theory that like every part of parenting
is both every part of parenting is both
difficult and magical at both exhausting
and electrifying and and so you just
have to kind of ride the waves of it and
understand that it's a wave I do think
it gets a lot easier once they start
sleeping at night which four-week-old
babies usually do not do yeah so it gets
easier once you start to be able to
sleep six or seven hours in a row
crystal and I hope for you that's around
11 or 12 weeks it might be longer but
that's my hope for you yeah and in
general I will suggest talking to other
parents or or you people who have like
realistic feelings about this oftentimes
like when I've been when I've read like
parent things like the gloss over the
fact that it's really hard and I think
that
no I think that's not the thing to do
yeah it's really easy to catastrophize
when you haven't slept much like the
longer you go without sleeping the more
minor problems seem to be existential I
think you are right John it is very hard
and especially when you are
sleep-deprived and everything this
morning I had to do the dishes and I was
like trying to do the dishes but I was
so tired and I broke a dish and I truly
felt like that was it you know that like
I'd reached the end of my experiment
with humaneness that my life was over I
just looking at it that dish is just
being like oh my god I've just added 15
minutes to my already busy day oh my god
ah we've got a somewhat related question
correct John that you would like to move
on to we do David sent us a very long
and wonderful email but I'm only going
to read the end of it which reads I'm
having a baby daughter next month and we
haven't been able to pick a name no we
won't use Ryan currently we have it
narrowed down to Kiera
Elena and Ori Ella Ori for short what is
your opinion we are open to other names
that aren't Ryan first off David I am
deeply offended and also you're making a
horrible mistake I think that you know I
think it's gonna be okay John I think
that David can make his own decisions
but what is the mistake you think he's
making no I don't agree at all Ori Ori
which is a lovely name by the way or
yell or Elia or or I don't know how to
say it but it's a lovely name Ori a URI
is actually an anagram of the name I'm
going to propose for this child are I a
and Ryan but there's no N in re I'm not
that good at anagrams it's funny because
you learn a whole book about yeah yeah
but I used an anagram generator I'm not
as smart as the kid in that book yeah
nice thing about writing writing books
about smart people you could take all
the time to make them smart and it seems
like you that they didn't take any time
at all I guess you could just name the
kid Ryu rot Rio rot Ryu right riah what
about like
or just rye you know when I was a kid
Hank I had an acquaintance whose name I
won't actually say it this is one of
those names where it's so uncommon that
it becomes very easy to google the
person if I say their name all I'll say
is that their name was an amalgam of the
two colors in the parents favorite
college football team
oh my am so for instance if it had been
the University of Alabama which it
wasn't the name might have been like I
believe it's the crimson and white so it
might have been like Krait chromite
that's a bad idea but the actual name
was so much worse than that but I don't
feel like I can I don't feel like I can
out this person so I can't I can't tell
the joke but anyway long story so tires
should clear social obviously named your
daughter Ryan you couldn't name your
child ory Ella and then call her rife or
short and that's kind of like Ryan or
just call her Ryan for short I mean
here's my case David when when your kid
asks of inevitably as they will in like
you know five to seven years well where
did my name come from you're gonna be
able to look at that child and you're
gonna be able to say it was an inside
joke on the Internet's two hundred and
thirty seventh most popular comedy
podcast yeah and that's something that
that kid is gonna take with them and
it's gonna keep them warm on cold nights
for the rest of their life yeah and what
you can say is it doesn't matter if
you're popular as long as you're funny
and aware of the inevitability of your
own demise memento mori we've got
another question John it's also about
children we're just gonna pick it all
the children one it's not really a
question it comes from read I just
wanted to tell you guys that one night
when I was crying on the couch with my
few weeks old son breastfeeding for the
billionth hour and I realized the baby's
umbilical stork was gone the dog was
chewing ominously since seriously red
boy thanks for that question people do
you know people people cook and to eat
the yeah
the umbilical well I don't know that you
can eat the put the
billick accordance we've got a lot of
connective tissue in it it's like
fingernail that was bad okay okay sorry
I'm so sorry
we're both very tired and I feel like I
in adequately answer that first question
but and I want to say that everyone
feels this way and it's terrible for
everyone when you have a tiny child and
you're not sleeping at all and it is
really hard and it does one of the
things that people did not prepare me
for when I was having a kid that like it
is not easy it is hard it is hard Hank I
want to read you a question that I need
the answer to and I'm hoping you have
the answer to it comes from Elena she
writes dear John and Hank recently
people have been telling me that eggs do
not need to go in the refrigerator that
seems silly to me as I work-wise what I
said lice eggs do need to go in the
refrigerator well I'll explain it it's
actually kind of complicated okay well I
won't even bother getting to the end of
the question although Elena had a lovely
email but you clearly don't want me to
read it because you cut me off by saying
lies why do you need to refrigerate your
eggs in it depends on where you live
remarkably enough in the u.s. we are
very careful about Salmonella maybe
because we like to eat our eggs pretty
raw here I don't know if that's the case
in other countries but we do and like to
not cook our eggs very much and so we
like the the Department of Agriculture
or the USDA that's the same thing or the
whoever handles the food regulations in
this country requires that eggs are
washed and so the eggs come out of the
chickens and then they get washed off so
that there's no stuff on that that might
give you disease but that also washes
off a bunch of proteins that like clog
up the pores and the eggs that make eggs
last much longer and basically don't
require them to be refrigerated so if
you get eggs from your chicken you don't
have to you don't have to refrigerate
those you can wash them beforehand or
you can basically not wash them at all
if you're not super concerned about it
in other countries eggs are not washed
in the same way and so they don't
refrigerate eggs and so sometimes people
go to other countries and they say look
look at all these eggs that aren't being
refrigerated why do we refrigerate our
eggs in America it's just because we're
crazy no maybe a little bit it's big but
you can't
not refrigerate eggs in America American
eggs do have to be refrigerated well
just another example of American
exceptionalism our eggs are cleaner than
anybody's we've got the cleanest eggs on
earth and the most refrigerated well
we're just trying to trying to keep
people alive and and that's that's what
we decided was a way to do it
Salmonella sucks I am strongly opposed
to Salmonella this next question we have
is from naialah who asks your green
brothers like how you avoided the
controversy there after listened to the
last week spot and hearing the fantastic
news of Beyonce's pregnancy to twins it
got me thinking it got me and my wife
thinking how long until everyone alive
on the planet is at least distantly
related to Beyonce like how many
generations do we have to make it before
we've gotten to the perfect utopia where
everyone currently alive is at least a
tiny bit Beyonce this question is very
important as my wife and I desperately
need some sort of plausible utopia to
look forward to in these dark times
Quaffle Zin gyoza niala
well I have good news and bad news Hank
I also have good news and bad news but
you go first okay so my bad news is that
I'm pretty sure humans won't survive
long enough for everyone on earth to be
related to Beyonce how long do you think
that would take John so I know that all
people of European descent are related
to are descended from Charlemagne the
and also everyone else who was alive
back then I'm not sure that all humans
are necessarily now in Europe right not
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and I know
that all living humans are descended
from Confucius and I know that almost
all living humans are descended from
Muhammad so it can't have been that long
but I also think those people from back
then had a big advantage because the
population was smaller uh-huh whereas
you know if you look a thousand years
into the future the human population is
probably going to it's pretty big now
and it's probably going to get a little
bit bigger and then stabilize and then
maybe slowly taper off
so I
I don't know the answer to this question
but I don't think that humans have a
very good chance of existing in two
thousand years which is how long I think
it would take I I think a two thousand
years is a good guess that I may I mean
the things that are gonna mess this up
though like the thing that could make it
much less is if there is some kind of
apocalyptic event and we lose a lot of
people then it's much easier for us to
all be related to each other quite
quickly because there will be only if we
make sure that Beyonce's descendants
survive which is key I mean obviously we
need to prioritize that it's key to this
happening but also it seems quite likely
I mean it seems to me that Beyonce's
descendants would have an above-average
chance of surviving just just by where
they are going to be on the
socio-economic spectrum sure but but
also because of just being amazing I
assume I don't want to put too much
pressure on Beyonce's children I was
gonna say no pressure unborn babies but
I will say that to be clear we are all
distantly related to Beyonce like we are
all already like we share so much in
common with Beyonce farm more than you
could imagine really we are so very
close to being exactly Beyonce hmm but
in addition to that we are all you know
related to everything on the planet
that's alive
so it's not actually that except it's
true that we are all related to Beyonce
we are also all related to like bananas
we're significantly close closer related
to people of our species than we are to
bananas but yeah III understand your
point I think it's important to remember
that you know the main thing that's
gonna be difficult about getting all
humans to be descended from Beyonce is
keeping humans around as a species for
another thousand years so I think that
if that if we just make that the focus
it will have this like unexpected right
wonderful side benefit of all of us
being descended from Beyonce and just
maybe like I don't know like 3,000 or
4,000 short generations definitely not
generations that's a long moment like
I'm sorry too
two or three hundred generations yeah I
think I'm so tired yes I see that an
entire I have to ask you an important
question Anna gramming I'm not good at
any part if I'm not good at any part of
I was gonna say video blogging but
that's not easy what we're doing right
now so my important question is how long
do you think it will be until all living
humans are descended from at least one
minion do you mean like the minions in
the movie minions mmm-hmm okay so I've
got good news and bad news and it's
actually the same news and it's just in
how you look at it like a lot of news
which is that minions are not real I
also think they're there they don't seem
to be they don't seem to reproduce
sexually if this is how is the sentence
that has created an awful image in my
brain yeah I mean I want to go back in
time to the part of life where I had
never considered many in reproduction
what I what I like to think of like the
healthy on days when America was
definitely not compromised by Vladimir
Putin and I didn't have to think about
minion sex I want to write a whole book
on minions sex now I just want to know
how it works
please please Joe speaking of John yeah
speaking of here's the question from
Ruby who asks dear Hank and John I've
noticed that a different households have
different norms for toilet use during
the night in my house we just flush like
all times of the day but at my friend's
houses they don't so that no one is
woken from the noise my question is if
I'm staying at someone else's house
should I flush or not it makes me
uncomfortable to leave it unflushed but
then again perhaps I should just do what
is the norm in that household thank you
for making the podcast Ruby I have so
this this I want to answer this question
because it it brings up a question that
I am curious about mmm-hmm this is
someone else's toilet definitely but the
water in the toilet yeah is kind of
public property
it's a understand that like it's been
paid for but it's kind of a public
service but the thing I put in the
toilet right that's mine
right I made that and so where does the
where's the line between what is my
in what is not mine like is the toilet
handle the toilet handles not mine so
should I not touch the toilet handle
because that's that's the not mine area
but I am trying to like I don't want it
I'm not trying to like push a toilet
handle I'm trying to eliminate the
existence of the thing that is mine and
so the toilet hand is just sort of a
mechanism through which I would like to
do that yeah I don't think anybody would
ever welcome you into their house and
say also don't touch any of the things
that are mine in this house because then
you'd have to be like wait but I'm I'm
currently my feet are on the floor what
do I do with my feet
so I I don't think you have to worry
about that I think that the answer here
is pretty clear which is if it's I can't
remember the exact rhyme from camp Hank
but perhaps you will if it's yellow just
stay mellow if it's brown flush it down
if it's yellow let it let it Mellow if
it's brown flush it down I agree that
you can't leave a duker there for
somebody to find in the morning
definitely not right no I think if it's
yellow 100 percent of the time you just
you just let it yellow well I think
that's probably good advice I believe
that by the way in general there's so
much unnecessary flushing of toilets in
the United States I this is a somewhat
off-topic rant but like the amount of
unnecessary flushing of toilets in the
u.s. is just baffling to me and and
that's spoken from the perspective of a
committed and extreme germaphobe it's
just ridiculous how often we flush after
a small pee it's just a little bit of
pee now if you have a dog or a small
child that drinks toilet bowl water then
maybe yes then maybe but other than that
there is no reason anyway let's move on
Hank I'm gonna otherwise I'm going to
lose my knife I have an addition I have
an addition Oh Kevin addition to make
which is that if it I think that rhyme
needs an addition if it's yellow let it
Mellow if it's brown flush it down if
it's yellow and poop or brown and pee
you go see a doctor it's okay to have a
little bit of somewhat brown pee on
occasion as long as you're dehydrated
but I honestly if you're getting your
health advice from your Hank and John
you've made some terrible life choices
oh god okay Johnny you got another
question not really I think I can find
one but I did the answer - did I have
one already is no no I didn't Oh
this question is from Adam I thought
this is pretty interesting Hank he'll he
writes hello best brothers that's too
high of a compliment Adam unfortunately
we're not able to accept it because of
the Gregory Brothers and also the Wright
brothers you know I mean without them we
wouldn't have air travel
don't get me wrong I'm I think we're
extraordinary but you know let's not
let's not blow it out of proportion Adam
anyway sometimes I feel like the only
way to have an impact on the world at
large is to first become rich and then
use my fiscal power to help people or
influence government however until I
acquire wealth what are some ways to
help steer this great American ship
toward kinder gentler and more accepting
destinations receptively yours Adam so
Hank you don't know a lot of rich people
like in your day-to-day life you don't
like hang out with rich people I am like
not to brag an anthropologist of rich
people I hang out with a bunch of rich
people and I am like a student of their
ways and Adam I will tell you a secret
about rich people which is that rich
people also believe that they need to
get rich in order to have an influence
on the world at large but they find as
they get richer as if by magic that they
are never quite rich enough yet to have
that influence that they're waiting to
have so you're already there my friend
you're just on a hamster wheel that as
long as you believe that one day you
will be rich enough to make a difference
you will just stay on that hamster wheel
trying to get richer and richer and
richer and richer and you will find over
time that you have more things to spend
money on you'll start to think oh man I
actually need to belong to this Country
Club and then if you get stupid rich
you'll start to think you know what I
need what would be better for everyone
including the world would be if I had a
private jet or a yacht
or whatever oh my god if you worship
money it will never be enough whatever
you worship it will it will never be
enough
and so that is my theory I think if you
if you try to make money to make a
difference in the end you're just gonna
stay on the hamster wheel yeah so try to
worship making a difference rather than
making money and but like Johnny do see
that like there are a lot of super rich
folk that do have this oversized
influence on politics yes there are
certainly more rich folks then choose to
do that it's interesting that a lot of
rich people choose to do other things
with their money whether that's you know
make more money with it or do good
things with it or or you know like get
it put it put it into like trying to get
candidates elected but I don't even know
that that works that well no I don't
think it does I think like spending
money to try to influence politics has
not been particularly effective in the
United States in the last 50 years now I
do think that you can influence like
state and local politics a lot but yeah
I sort of eyeing campaign ads doesn't
work I think lobbying works but yeah I
just think in general if I think you
said it perfectly Hank if you if the
focus is not on how can I get money so I
can change the world or how can I get
money so I can make life better for the
people around me but instead on how can
I make life better for the people around
me
it's a much more fulfilling way of
living and I was I I know I was like
being way oversimplifying in my in my
little rant so I want to be clear about
that but I I do really really believe
that it's just never it's never enough
if it's what if it's the end like so
make like Hank said make the end
something that never having enough of it
will be good Hank
is there an inherent meaning to human
life or is it constructed by us
is this a question from a listener John
or is this just you've decided to ask
the big one no I just wonder what you
think is there like an inherent
objective meaning to human life or are
we just here to turn oxygen into carbon
dioxide
because because you can't say is there
an inherent objective meaning or is
there no meaning at all because there's
them there's the second thing I think
that you like there could be a case to
be made that there is an inherent and
inherent objective meaning to life and
which is which is the continuation of
life that is a it is a natural process
it is a it is beyond natural it is a
physical process the way that life is a
physical process is very complicated and
cool and I'd like I want to get into it
but not right now
but I think that there's also something
to be said that like if you want to if
you want to create a sort of like an
easily objectifying purpose for life you
can there are a number of things that
you can put it on I like to put it on
complexity I think that like the the
work that is being done by all organisms
but by humans better than any organism
is like organization of things like
putting putting molecules together in
ways that that would not happen without
a life to put them together in that way
mm-hmm fighting against entropy
basically like kind of the goal against
life is just to kind of catch entropy on
its way down and be like while you're
crashing down toward a state of disorder
we're gonna do something interesting
with this and so there's like that's
like a like a way of talking about the
purpose of life and in a way that like
is fundamental to physics but I think
that really it's all internal to humans
and I but that doesn't make it not real
right and I think so yeah I mean like I
that we both agree that there is a
purpose to life but it is decided upon
by the things that are doing the living
right one of the things that and there's
nothing that doesn't make it less real
one of the things I've been thinking
about a lot recently is how there is
something beautiful and heroic and
fascinating about the process of humans
and also other animals but especially
humans making something in a place where
previously existed nothing like that's
what a great story or a great work of
art or a great poem does right is like
it creates inside of you an experience
or a space where there was previously
nothing it like takes what there's a
line from William Faulkner's Nobel Prize
speech that I don't want a butcher so
I'm going to Google it because I'm no
dummy right at the beginning of this
that this Nobel Prize speech the
greatest Nobel Prize speech I think in
the history of the universe Faulkner
said I feel that this award was made not
to me as a man but to my work a life's
work in the agony and sweat of the human
spirit not for glory and least of all
for profit but to create out of the
materials of the human spirit something
which did not exist before and that
process of making things from
essentially nothing making something
that didn't exist before that is a cool
thing that all humans do and we do it
like directly and other animals do it
too but humans are really good yeah we
do it directly into each other all the
time like that's what communication is
is like rightist creation of a thing and
and and like our conception of ourselves
even and of the people that like that we
know well enough to conceive of it's
pretty cool I mean it like I'm starting
to feel a little homey - good job John
today's podcast is brought to you by the
meaning of life the meaning of life it
we think there is one podcast it's also
brought to you by the P and the toilet
just leave it it's fine
pee in the toilet just leave it that's a
good song it's a really good song Hank
did you write that just now oh yeah it's
part of my new ad camp
I'm working on 4b in the toilet we
really need better market incentives to
preserve natural resources and and so I
actually think that's a pretty good idea
and of course today's podcast is also
brought to you by Beyonce's descendants
Beyonce's descendants soon enough
hopefully God willing all of us also
this podcast is brought to you by the
weird lumpy stump left behind when your
baby's umbilical cord falls off it's
real gross and your dog loves it
mmm it's probably my least favorite
sponsor we've ever had it's right up
there with up there with mating minions
in these fun things that have ever
happened on our podcast this question is
from Nicole John who asked dear Hank and
John trying to write high fantasy I
wanted to talk a little bit more about
about creating things in your brain yeah
I thought a lot about the magic system
and the history and the big ideas of the
world but I keep running into miniscule
problems like what they eat and how they
mark time passing and how do they get
from place to place the real problem is
I feel like in order to create a world I
need to know sociology psychology
history biology astronomy if I'm making
a planet or moon politics basically
everything so my question is how would I
go about learning absolutely everything
about how people and the world works
rebel forever Nicole people are taking
the sign off seriously and I love it
yeah I love that people are really
trying to find a good sign of although
you'll never find one better than
memento mori
I mean ending all of your emails memento
mori it puts you into a next level of
person like it just means that everybody
you know is gonna be like oh wow that's
my memento mori' friend anyway damn my
my mentor and first editor Eileen Cooper
who worked with me at book whist
magazine and helped me write and rewrite
Looking for Alaska many times before it
was ever published used to say that the
hardest thing about writing is getting a
character to walk through a door and
there are times when you can be
paralyzed by the complexity of trying to
use language
to get another person to imagine walking
through a door you know where you you
almost like get stuck inside of that and
I don't write high fantasy I am not good
at world building almost all of my
novels are set in places where I have
lived but I do think that there's an
element of trying when you're writing of
trying to see it from the perspective of
the reader rather than from your own
perspective what's gonna make the reader
feel like this is real what's going to
immerse them in the world which are the
details whether it's psychology or
astronomy or whatever that's gonna make
it feel real to them rather than being
obsessed with trying to make it as real
as you can for yourself
that's a hard line but I think like that
act of empathy of trying to imagine the
readers experience is like the essential
thing about writing yeah Patrick
Rothfuss talks about this and has talked
to me about it several times just
because I've been interviewing him for
something or another thing because we're
friends and his uh his advice is like
you don't have to talk about all the
things you have to talk about the things
that you know well and so he talks about
the fact that like he's kind of obsessed
with currency like in his normal life
he's obsessed with how money works and
so the money is a really fleshed out
thing in the king Hillier kiddin Killer
chronicles like they talk about making
change and all these different cultures
have different money and they have to
like figure out how to like like have
one kind of money work in another place
and but like you know for example george
RR martin clearly doesn't know anything
about how planets work because
oftentimes things will happen on the
planet that doesn't make any sense and
that's fine because it's fantasy and
like maybe there's some way that this
that there's like the winter would last
much longer sometimes than it does other
times but like that doesn't it doesn't
like make sense based on how we think
about how planets work but it doesn't
really matter
he doesn't really go into why the winter
gets longer some years than other years
mm-hmm
um or why winters could can go on for
years he just says that it does and
that's a thing right
and and and that's okay to not have that
part of the world be fleshed out because
like the politics of that world are
extraordinarily fleshed out and that
makes it seem real so you have to like
focus on one thing and you don't have to
like be like alright well I have to make
a new kind of animal for them to eat
because they have to eat food but it
doesn't I don't want to just be a deer
no just have it be a deer right in
general fine but they can eat deer the
magic of world-building for me like the
way that I learn about it is from
reading about it like the way that I
learn about good world building is from
reading books with good world building
in general I think that reading is such
a good apprenticeship for any writer so
I would look at your favorite high
fantasy novels and I would see how are
they doing it what is the stuff that
they're glossing over and I don't even
think about it or worry about it as a
reader because they're focusing on this
other stuff so well and it gives it that
granularity and that texture that makes
it feel feel like you're inside of the
story and feel like these are real
people and a lot of times for me like
what really makes a novels
world-building stand out is its
character development like I will
believe almost anything and never even
occurred to me until just now that
winter can't be long Hank never crossed
my mind
because I'll believe almost anything if
the characters are developed well and
really like what sets george RR martin
or patrick rothfuss apart from the vast
majority of authors including me is
character building yeah or you know you
know another another before we go
another writer who I would highly
recommend on world building character
building front is NK jemisin if you read
any NK jemisin books Hank I have not oh
my god so good and I don't even as you
know I'm not huge on the SF fantasy
world but oh my gosh well gotta let it
write it down because I'm looking for
good stuff right now but boy do I want
some thing to read that isn't the news
John yeah do you have news from AFC
Wimbledon I do Hank and you know it is
it is complicated
it's it's so here's what happened okay
a couple things happened since we last
visited checked in with AFC Wimbledon
first off they played Charlton Charlton
Athletic it's a so Charlton's coach is a
guy named Carl Robinson and he used to
be the coach of the franchise currently
playing in Milton Keynes and he said
some very disrespectful things about AFC
Wimbledon over the years he's been very
much kind of like a Bond villain in the
way that he talks about the club and
he's just he's an extremely unlikable
person I don't like to say it's you know
like judge people but like he is like
not liked by a wide swath of the
footballing world and AFC Wimbledon were
losing 1 nil to Charlton in the 94th
minute when Tom Elliot England's
greatest lyric poet and also AFC
Wimbledon's current best striker hit a
stunning tying goal thank goodness to
tie that game and then in the aftermath
of that game something was said by
someone to Carl Robinson and Carl
Robinson reacted very violently and had
to be restrained and yeah I don't know
so there there's a lot of hullabaloo
going on with it a lot of people
discussing if the person who said
something I don't even know who who it
was it was somebody who worked with the
club on a volunteer basis should be
suspended or fired or whatever and a lot
of other people saying but Carl Robinson
is a Bond villain and sometimes you have
to say bad things to Bond villains it's
complicated I don't I don't think it
does the club any good obviously to
verbally abuse opponents but also I
though even the way Carl Robinson talks
about AFC Wimbledon in interviews about
that it just makes me so mad I can
barely focus that's so like I kind of
get it and I'm not I'm not somebody who
got my club taken away by these
jackasses
anyway then on Valentine's Day AFC
Wimbledon played Coventry City who are
currently last in Ligue 1 and their last
by a lot and it was a home game which is
the kind of game that you have to win
when you're playing the last-place team
and we were down 1 nil in the 95 not
again again and again got bailed out
this time by a goal from Paul Robinson
Center back who I believe is a hundred
and seventeen years old now so it was a
very impressive performance from him but
it does mean that AFC Wimbledon has
slipped a little further back now after
30 games of the 46 games season they are
they have 39 points and are currently
14th so the critical number is that the
team that is in the is in the the
relegation spot at the moment the last
door the last four teams all go down
and currently bury or burry it's spelled
like the word like to bury a human I
don't
all these place teams place names are
made up but they're in 21st place on 31
points having played 32 games basically
Hank if at the end of the season at the
end of the 46 game season AFC Wimbledon
has 50 points they will probably stay up
if they have 52 points they will almost
definitely stay up so the key is to get
13 points from the remaining 15 games
that should be doable but tying Coventry
City 1-1 in the last second of the game
is the kind of development that makes me
a little nervous going into the the last
part of the season here I understand
your trepidation John
I wish the boys all the best thank you
we appreciate that what's the Mars deuce
you you know what the United Arab
Emirates are right John I do I already I
actually read this Mars news Hank I am
getting so good at Mars news well they
as you might know it have a lot of money
yeah and so are in a weird way like a
sort of like a hotbed for what can be
done if you have a lot of money mm-hmm
to to throw around you know all that
good oil money that's coming in right
now and and a little bit of like boy we
should probably figure out how to grow
our economy while we have this money so
that because someday we won't happen
anymore cuz oil runs out mm-hmm and they
have launched a just sort of announced a
like sort of a like it's a it's the
plans
it's the actual plans to build a city on
Mars by 2117 now I know that that's
nowhere near 2028 it's quite quite a
distance from 2028 it's the kind of time
when I will definitely be dead but it's
you know it wouldn't say definitely 20
that's right it's positive what do we be
a hundred and forty I'll be a hundred
and thirty-seven yeah I mean I don't
love your odds I would say that it's
under 1% but I bet that by 2117 somebody
will be alive at the age of 137 really
that's that's a nice thing to think I
thought you were gonna say somebody will
be alive and I was like yeah that's my
brother's pessimism 2117 someone will
still be alive but Sheikh Muhammad the
Dubai ruler on Tuesday announced the
Mars 2117 project which aims to build a
miniature city on the planet Mars by one
within 100 years also the vice president
and prime minister of the UAE Sheikh
Mohammed he said they were currently
among the world's top 9 investors in
space science which is true it gets a
you know there's a long tail there right
in a series of tweets accompanied by
photos of what it describes as the
planets first miniature city he said
2117 Mars part is aimed to build
knowledge and scientific capabilities
involve the cun
conversion of local universities into
research centers the project launched at
the world government summit will focus
on parallel research into exploring the
means of mobility housing energy as well
as speeding up the time it takes to
travel to the planet
so there we go go go off all right
United Arab Emirates I mean I would love
to see a city on Mars in 2117 mostly
because it would mean that I'm still
alive ya know I would definitely also
love to see it I'd love to see anything
in 2170 I don't know yeah I do a little
worried a little bit about my quality of
life if I'm alive at 137 years old but
maybe maybe it'll be okay Beyonce's
twins will only be 99 they've got a
chance they've got a good chance they
can they might go to Mars they might go
to Mars they might they've got it
they've got a chance Hank do you think
there's any possibility of you going to
Mars no no no no no definitely not all
right I have too many I have too many
disorders I wouldn't be among the first
the cream of the crop
yeah they don't they don't need anybody
who has to use the toilet as much as me
yeah I feel like having ulcerative
colitis on Mars would not be fun no no I
think I'm going to state where the
medical infrastructure is yeah yeah I've
been thinking about that recently
because I've been thinking about like
lovely places where I could move because
it's just so cold here all the time and
also flat but that I'm always torn
because you know like I have a doctor
here and a dentist and a good
relationship with the hospitals which
provide excellent care ah anyway
um Hank that's the oldest person thing
I've ever said I have officially entered
late middle age hey before we go I just
have to share a few quick Corrections
first in our last episode I said that
AFC Wimbledon have been promoted five
times in their brief and illustrious
history as several people pointed out
that in fact they have been promoted six
times in their brief illustrious history
because I was forgetting about last year
also in a recent episode you mentioned
the twin astronauts mark and John who
took part in a study on the effects of
spending extended period of time in
outer space on the human body by sending
them one of them into space Hannah
pointed out that you got the the twin
name I got wrong Mark Kelly was not the
twin that spent a year in space it was
Scott sorry Scott and also mark also
laying wrote in to say that in a recent
episode of the podcast we
that mammoths and mastodons have hooves
they don't they have feet like elephants
and then Lang sent in a very attractive
photograph of the bones of mammoth feet
which we will put on the patreon I mean
you can just picture the feet from the
bones it made me very glad that I was
not alive during the same time that they
were alive when humans were not at the
top of the food chain I loved being at
the top of the food chain and lastly
about 500,000 people wrote in on the
topic of what would happen if gravity
was suspended from earth for 15 seconds
and I have to say the answer is varied
wildly yes Cavan though I I've I've been
I looked at this and I tried to figure
out who was more correct and I feel like
Kalam showed his work and and and
centered in on sort of a consensus area
which is that the the height the fall
would range from around four point four
meters to around 1.6 meters if you sort
of like if like the earth turned away
from under you as you floated out
depending on where you are on the earth
though of course if you were at the pole
you wouldn't move at all and four point
four is enough to hurt you pretty bad I
will say though that if you're in a
building you're only gonna go as high as
the ceiling you'll just hit the ceiling
and you can like push yourself back down
so that's good so that from what I what
I have learned from this exercise is
don't go outside
Calem use the the sign off protons and
pulsars and we're gonna put the math
that he or she I think he has done on
the patreon so that you can see and
compare notes to see if we are correct
at what would happen if gravity turned
off for fifteen seconds okay Hank what
have we learned today
well John we learned that you have to
refrigerate your eggs if you're in
America because of weird stuff we
learned that David should definitely
name his child Bryan or possibly just
Rai or possibly Oh
I just came up with that one but I like
it and we learned that we are all
already related to Beyonce as well as to
minions somehow I think not related to
minions they are not real Hank I mean if
we learned one thing from this podcast
is that we were gonna stop talking about
minions as if they were real we're gonna
treat them as fictional characters
forever and after period end of story
that is the one thing that we learned
from this podcast I'm not even gonna
continue with the what do we what do we
learn bit because that is the thing that
we learned we have learned the thing
that we learned which is that minions
will be treated as a fiction and like
many other fictions as a fiction that
does not reproduce thank you for
listening to our podcast thanks
everybody for listen to our podcast do
not do what I just did I won't even tell
you what I just did but don't do it I
used to exhaust it I used Google I did a
thing you shouldn't do obviously never
use good never use Google in a situation
like that anyway moving on you can email
us at Hank and John and gmail comm we're
never talking about menus on this
podcast ever again we talked about
minions for the last time this is a is a
Dominion podcast from here on out you
can email us at Hank and John and sheet
milcom you can send us you tweets as
well if you want with the hashtag dear
Hank and John or you can you can tweet
us directly I'm John Green Hank is Hank
green this podcast this podcast is
produced for OCR halse rojas and sherrod
gibbs in our editor is Nicholas Jenkins
Victoria banners a head of community and
communications and our music is by the
great gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]